donc toute organisation interne du
château qui apparaît je vous ai dit
défensive ici agricole de l'autre côté
avec la ferme et vous voyez que le mur a
été reconstruit dans les années 1850
donc re cadastre et domestiques avec le
puits
les cuisines et l'habitat qui se
trouvait de ce côté de l'ancien château
de grignols il ne reste que quelques
vestiges comme les douves ses tourelles
et ce jardin à la française un domaine
baptisé l'autre d'honneur de madame de
maintenon les pouces secrète de louis
xiv
voilà maintenant en tout cas là le
château de grignols puisqu'on a des
documents montrant l'achat par louis xiv
pour madame de maintenon en 787
notamment pour la dédommager les travaux
de l'aqueduc qui se faisaient pour
alimenter les autres versailles dans son
propre château à la place du château
démanteler existe aujourd'hui cette
demeure une gentilhommière construite à
la fin du xviiie siècle
olivier beaud rejet et son compagnon
l'ont achetée il ya quatre ans il
travaille depuis à la restauration des
pièces comme ce grand salon qui nous
plonge au xviiie siècle avec son plafond
peint son clavecin et ses jeux d'époque
olivier espère pouvoir ouvrir cette
pièce et toutes les autres au public
d'ici l'été prochain
ce grand salon qu'on a voulu très
régence dans son décor en clin d'oeil un
peu madame de maintenon à qui
appartenait le domaine eh bien je qui
s'intègre dans dans d'autres pièces à
faire visiter comme une sorte de petit
musée vivant un peu avec une approche
pédagogique de moi même chance aignan
pour que les gens puissent voilà
comprend des ambiances différentes qui
pouvaient exister au xviiie siècle
seul anachronisme ce perroquet il fait
partie de la quarantaine d'animaux de
sauvetage recueilli si la plupart sont
en liberté dans le domaine notamment les
chevaux et les poneys valises évolué
dans les sous bois du domaine alors tout
le domaine et fermez bien sûr mais on
voulait pas simplement les mettre dans
une pâture ils sont vraiment ils nous
aident en fait aussi bien c'est
d'ailleurs d'être écologique temps
chèvres et poneys tous peuvent ainsi
déambulé croiser les visiteurs dans cet
écrin de verdure de 9 hectares de
l'époque de madame de maintenon